the Whitney biopic I want to dance with
somebody hits theaters Friday and it's
important to point out that this film
has the full support of the Houston
family with British actress naomiacki
transforming literally into the music
legend yeah the movie comes 10 years
after Whitney's tragic passing and
tonight we celebrate the real Whitney
the woman the mother and the voice of a
generation
[Music]
Whitney Elizabeth Houston now anybody in
her Circle or her family members they
called her nippy her daddy her daddy
gave you that nickname we used to call
he called her nippy used to call me
Newfie what do you think fans would be
most surprised to discover about Whitney
Houston
Phil be glad to know that I'm like them
just you know regular
she wanted to you know let's go to White
Castles in a limousine so just a lot of
fun a lot of fun
she loved to swim
she was almost like an Olympic swimmer
but these are all things that people
don't know
[Music]
why would I do for fun as uh I'm just
very peaceful I stayed home most of the
time
she was lazy as all you know what
she loved watching television she loved
sleeping I was planning on becoming a
teacher or a veterinarian but after
learning that I Could Sing instantity of
blood I guess I just never really leave
so
[Music]
you're about helping people she had a
huge heart
she fed people she clothed people she
helped send people to school to know the
Whitney that I know to know the Whitney
that I knew is to truly know that you
were blessed to know an amazing human
being before you ever got to the voice
if you got a chance to know her heart
that was something special do you want
to see some Lions today
yeah the Bronx Zoo
was desperately in need of some lion
cubs and I happen to know of some
I thought that I'd donate them to the
zoo
Whitney had one of the biggest hearts
she embraced the next generation of
singers I remember Brandy
talking about how emotional she became
when she first met Whitney
I'm happy this is Whitney Houston oh my
God
I love Monica and Brandi that was to
Whitney that was the the future of music
she would love others more than she
loved herself
when I was 18 I lost my grandmother I
lost I witnessed the suicide I lost my
cousin Whitney didn't call on the phone
three black trucks pulled up in the hood
and she jumped out
she's got the security outside suited
and booted and she's pretty much giving
them the hand she was on tour when when
I lost my second eldest brother and
we're in the middle of the service
and everybody everybody goes to whistle
you know Whispering they're whispering
and I'm like what is it whisper it is
with me she is
somehow made it to Detroit Michigan made
it to the funeral and she's walking in
by herself
I remember being in a car accident and
Whitney she came over and I think she
she slept in my bed in the room with me
for two days she would not leave
you know
this Fame and the success thing Man it
comes and it goes you know you're hot
today and not tomorrow or you know that
kind of thing so
it's it's important to know that um you
have family and friends that love you
for you and not because you got a number
one song on charts
there can be Miracles the world
remembers Whitney as the voice her
tragic passing came the night before the
Grammys a decade ago in 2012 but her
very first Grammy appearance that was
back in 1986. if I win that'll that'll
be something
[Applause]
I knew it was me because Dion said
Whitney would go on to win six Grammys
but a lot of people wonder where did she
keep them well at first you know in
shattered Mansion in New Jersey she
would encase them downstairs and now
since her passing
I keep them archived here in Georgia
[Music]
this is her dress from her first Grammy
performance look at that look how tiny
she is when the Grammy goes to
I want to dance with somebody with me
Grammy number two came in 1988 but it
was really 1994 there was Whitney's year
she had four nominations she won three
Grammys that year and who can forget how
she opened the show
[Music]
2012 was the last time the Grammys would
pay tribute to Whitney the day after her
passing Heavenly Father
we thank you for sharing our sister
Whitney with us when if we love we love
you
but we met Whitney long before she was a
grammy-winning superstar in fact she was
just 20 years old singing with Jermaine
Jackson a full year before she released
her debut album
[Music]
what everyone forgets about Whitney she
was a model before she was a singer
people in the modeling business really
never knew that I did sing
so when they found out that I did sing
it was like oh so besides that you can
sing so let's let's deal with that too
[Music]
[Applause]
God gave me something really great and
he doesn't give it to everybody
Whitney's gift was on full display when
she performed the national anthem at the
Super Bowl in 1991.
they wanted her to lip sync this song
she didn't want to do it
because she can't lips ain't good
she said I want it singing and she sang
it
and she sang it
I kind of blocked everything out and I
kind of went to the Persian Gulf where
the fellas were
it was for them that I I sang it for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
1991 was a huge year for Whitney you had
that Star-Spangled Banner moment and
then she started filming The Bodyguard
but a lot of people thought that's where
her acting career began it wasn't
one of Whitney's first acting gigs was
in 1985 on the Ricky Schroeder show
Silver Spoons
playing myself and I'm performing I'm
doing a video at this club I find that
it comes sort of naturally in a way I
mean being a performer
[Music]
yeah I got a film coming up
this is my first thing I mean you
haven't seen me in any movies have you
lately
[Music]
so the story behind The Bodyguard is
pretty incredible because Kevin Costner
called Whitney directly and said you are
the only person I can Envision playing
this role and if you don't accept this
part we're not going to make the movie
I thought that she was like really worth
it you know and in fact we postponed the
movie for a year which then said
everybody you're waiting a year for
someone that doesn't even know how to
act you know I said yeah we're going to
do that
foreign
[Music]
things to do I was like all right well
don't put your tongue in my mouth first
of all yeah
I did
I close my eyes and I
exhaled
[Music]
I liked that there was finally going to
be a film about African-American women I
believe in you and me in the uh meetings
that we had there was talk about Julia
Roberts but Whitney made so much sense
for so many reasons Denzel corn at me
and he said Whitney you're going to do
this movie you can sing gospel I said
tinsel you've never heard me saying
gospel he said yeah but I've heard your
mother
I thought Boy you know you know how to
get me good right
who are you
I'm your Fairy Godmother honey
she called me and asked me if I would be
Cinderella it flatters me really to have
someone who who loves me that much who
listens to me she listens to me intently
[Applause]
stop get on my face get out of my face
man we saw all sides of Whitney Houston
and Bobby Brown in the 2005 reality
series being Bobby Brown the couple of
17 years had a tumultuous Love Story
dealing with personal struggles in
public and in private
I can tell you this I love Bobby and
Bobby loves me
Whitney first met Bobby in 1989 at the
Soul Train Awards she was very excited
about meeting Bobby four months later
Bobby showed up to her 26th birthday
party and that's kind of when everything
just started
Whitney Whitney Whitney
um she invited me I'm having a great
time
Whitney and Bobby said I do in 1992 and
in those early years the two of them had
a lot of fun together boy do I remember
sometimes I get a call
um Miss Pat
um I think Whitney and Bobby forgot to
pay their their tab can you come over
and I'm like no they didn't you know I
have to go over to the restaurant and
everybody who said what a what an
interesting
mismatched relationship it was
lazy they have no idea they don't know
either he or I to say that we are
mismatched you know not long after
Whitney and Bobby got married Whitney
revealed to the world that she was
expecting in a couple of months it's
going to come out and it's going to be
these hands and his face and his feet
you know it's exciting she wanted a
strong family you know and so she was
determined not to allow the business
to stop that from happening
what do you think has been the biggest
price
for fame that you had to pay my privacy
my life my mother
and it's not a joke anymore damn the
jokes
it's not funny
she's seven today and
I want her to stay forward so Bobby
Christina was about to start her own
singing career she wanted to follow in
her mother's footsteps mom's excited
we're all ready for it Bobby Christina
or Chrissy would pass away just three
years after Whitney tragically and in an
eerily similar way
it's still hard just to process all of
that and wrap your brain around what
happened with the two of them uh it's a
day many of us will never forget it's
the day we lost Whitney
[Music]
Sparkle was Whitney Houston's Fifth and
final film role before her death on
February 11 2012. the movie is dedicated
to her memory it was also the last
project E.T spoke to Whitney about as we
look back on the final days of her life
well there's a bridge
and there's a river I'm at a good Pace
you know what I'm saying I'm not in any
rush to be a biggest star or anything I
have nothing to prove
[Music]
she was ready to live
ready to love ready to start a new
chapter
he watches
thank you Lord
over me
the last time I spoke to Whitney was the
week
that she passed I called her before she
got on the plane
to go to California which is I'm on my
way to sing for Clive going to the
Grammys and that was the last time
Whitney's very last performance was on
stage with Kelly Price in a small
nightclub and it was completely
unplanned I feel like that's kind of a
gift that God gave me because even if we
didn't know he knew
[Music]
I was having a Grammy celebration party
I wasn't expecting her to sing it all
um she came up on the stage she made her
way to the stage and she was like give
me the microphone
[Music]
[Applause]
Whitney was rasping that night she was
working very hard to do what was
necessary to get it back to where it was
Whitney wanted to talk to me this was a
few days prior she asked me Pat why do
people judge me
that was the first time she'd really
spoken about being judged that's I'm
just going to stay out here with her
until we go back we can go back together
and I didn't realize that on that Monday
I was taking her home taking her home
to Jersey taking her home to her mother
no one never knows I sang a song at her
homegoing at her funeral called Don't
Cry For Me don't cry
[Music]
a song that I recorded years before that
but also a song that Whitney used to
sing in her show
[Music]
it came from my heart and um
I believe it would have made her really
happy
we tried to preach Styles down that day
we were wrapped
Kevin Costner
well I had no idea I was a preacher's
kid snatched my heart in his hand so off
you go Whitney
off you go
escorted by an army of angels
to your heavenly father
probably the most gripping moment for me
was when the service was over and the
pallbearers grabbed her casket and in
sink they raised her casket to start
walking and they started playing I Will
Always Love You and when they walk past
Mama [ __ ]
he stepped out and she laid her hand on
the casket and she just dropped her head
it was real at that moment
[Music]
there are moments where I feel towards
the end of her life she had decided
I'm gonna be me you get it how you get
it
[Music]
the fact is no voice Has Come Close
no one sacrificed as much as she did me
that's all I want to be is me I can't
emulate anyone's career because this is
my career you know and I don't think
that anyone who will come you know after
me will be able to emulate mine she was
so amazing I mean that's all you can say
about her she was amazing the voice the
voice now before we go make sure to
catch I want to dance with somebody in
theaters on Friday and we're going to
leave you now with Whitney in her own
words she will never be forgotten ever
and may she always rest in power
I think I was born to perform hello good
evening
[Music]
[Applause]
it's training if you actually live in
one
I don't live in a suitcase I need to
sing
I don't need a career
it's wonderful that I have one and it's
been very good to me I worked very hard
at it but I need my family more than I
need a career I open my mouth and sing
and people took me in they received me
and I'm I'm grateful I really am
foreign